okay hey everyone um my name is Jessica
Ma and um thank you very much for tuning
into my presentation um I understand
that I am the last session of the day so
an extra thanks for sticking around and
and waiting for this talk um what I'm
going to do today is talk about some of
the work that has recently uh been done
in our lab the title of my presentation
is identifying transcriptional
Regulators of human embryonic
development by expression variability
and I'd just like to remind you guys if
you have any questions along the way
please feel free to submit your
questions and um I'd love to answer them
at the end of the
presentation so let's go ahead and and
get started um the focus of this talk is
around transcriptional regulation of
embryonic development now we all know
that as an embryo um there are very
there are various key devel velopmental
stages um that these embryos transition
through to develop normally and a big
part of regulating that transition is
how the transcriptomes are controlled so
there's a paper um that came out of at
the end of last year in nature
structural and molecular biology from
Yan edel and they were the first to
produce a data set um based on single
cell RNA SE profiling of human embryos
and embryonic stem cells and so this was
a really exciting Advance which allowed
us to really look at how transcripton
were changing during embryonic
development now just to step back a
little bit um the focus of my lab here
at Albert Einstein is to really focus on
how genes are regulated through
transcriptional regulatory networks and
as we know genes are expressed with both
signal but as we're starting to
understand as well
the level of precision or the degree of
noise which these genes are expressed
also has functional implications so if
you think about what's going on within a
single cell and you think about how
components of a regulatory Network are
controlled um you can imagine that genes
with low variance or low variability in
their expression are more uniformly
expressed between cells so if we were to
sample any cell at random from a
population the chances are that level of
a particular Gene is highly predictable
because it's quite similar from cell to
cell at The Other Extreme you can
imagine that genes that are more uh
variable or have much higher variance in
their expression reflect greater
heterogenity so that if you're looking
at the population of cells these cells
adopt different levels of gene
expression for this particular Gene and
you can imagine then the functional
consequences Downstream depending on the
roles that gen these genes are involved
in so another way to think about gene
expression variance is as a population
specific parameter and this is something
that our lab has been doing for a little
while now where you can think about two
groups usually a disease group and a
control group that you're interested in
contrasting
phenotypically and what we tend to do is
we look at gene expression differences
from the perspective of average
and we identify genes that are
differentially expressed based on how
different they are in terms of average
expression in the disease group and the
control group um and in in this setting
uh where traditionally we use a t
statistic in this case the variances
between the two groups will be the same
um and likely minimized so this is a
very sensible way to identify elements
that characterize the phenotype but one
aspect uh that we're missing out on is
the ability to identify genes that have
different degrees of variability between
these two groups so um one example would
be for instance um that's shown at the
bottom of the slide is where uh the
expression of a gene is quite widely
distributed in the disease group and in
contrast quite precisely distributed in
the control group and an more extreme uh
example of this is where on average the
expression of this Gene
is the same in the disease and the
control group but as you can see the
variability or the the variance of this
expression is is quite different now
using traditional approaches like the T
statistic we would miss out on
identifying these genes and so a lot of
our work has gone into trying to make
sense of how variability and variance
can help us understand regulation of
disease and different
phenotypes so uh another um kind of
motivation uh particularly in looking at
single cells is this realization that
when we drill things down to the Single
Cell level gene expression is
actually actually reflects as discrete
states in the population and a way to
demonstrate this is a work that we've
done with our collaborators where we've
taken uh or they've taken rather um
single cell gene expression from um the
H three cell line and what they've done
is they've sorted these hory cells
according to a cell surface marker cd9
which represents the degree of plop
potency so what we have are are these
fact sorted different subpopulations of
the same celline that reflect different
degrees of C potency and you can see as
you move from left to right in this on
the slide we go from uh increase to
decrease levels of cd9 protein
expression now because we have the level
of protein expression for this Gene we
can also look at the actual gene
expression or transcript distributions
of the cd9 uh Gene and when we look at
the individual single cell profiling
which we've obtained using fluid biomark
um what you see for the 100 cells are
these discrete distributions so for
instance um and I should point out that
this is CT data so as you probably know
the higher the level of CT um the lower
the degree of expression and the lower
the CT value corresponds to genes that
are more highly expressed so what's
really interesting here is you see the
discreteness of cd9 transcript
expression as you go from high to low
levels of protein expression you can see
that for the highest degree of cd9
protein expression we see 100% of the
cells in this High transcript expression
State and contrast that that with the
least uh or the lowest level of cd9
protein expression where you see that
the majority of cells are actually in
this off state where there's no
transcript expression of cd9 um and
there's a small uh small subset of cells
that are expressing cd9 and everything
in between is kind of interesting
because it's this balance between genes
that are in the off State at CT value of
40 and another set of cells that are
actually expressing the cd9 transcript
and as you go from high to medium to low
levels of cd9 protein expression what
we're seeing is this transfer cells
moving from the on to the off State as
opposed to something like a bell curve
that's shifting on average to lower
degrees of cd9 expression so this is a
real plug I guess for looking at gene
expression distributions and by proxy
variability in single SLE cell gene
expression because if we just looked at
average expression we'd miss these
subgroups that are clearly uh there in
the population so let's go back to uh
human embryonic development and talk
about the data set that we've been using
from Yan at all um what we've got here
from from the paper is as I said a
single cell RNA sequencing data set uh
that's about 20 to 60 million 100 Bas
per reads per cell there are three
embryos for each velopment to Stage
except for Mora where we had two embryos
from the paper um as far as uh they
State all embryos were morphologically
normal um on appearance and so basically
what we're working with is an increasing
number of cells for two to three embryos
at each developmental stage so if you
have a look at the data from um an
overall perspective we're working with
the rpkm normalized data um there were
some filters that were passed to enure
quality of the data and we've adopted
them in our analysis too we've taken a
threshold of point1 to uh retain the
genes that were uh expressed or more
highly expressed and we've required that
that be the case in at least 75% of
cells from the same stage this gives us
um about 8,000 genes to work within our
analysis and this is spread across about
cells so in terms of measuring
variability uh there are are different
ways we can do this and in our analysis
what we've done is adopted two different
statistics to understand how variability
is occurring in expression at the level
of cells and embryos so if you imagine
that X is the expression of a gene in a
specific cell in a specific embryo what
we've done is we've calculated the SDC
which represents the intercellular
variability in the one embryo so we can
imagine that STC represents how much the
gene expression fluctuates for the same
gene from cell to cell within an
embryo and basically what we do is we
look at the intercellular variability by
averaging this SDC that we've obtained
for one embryo over the multiple embryos
that we have available so that this is
the best estimate that we have for
intercellular variab
we can also look at heterogenity or
variability within the embryo as well
and for that we calculate the inter
embryo variability where we're looking
at how this
sdcj statistic uh fluctuates about the
mean SDC that we can obtain for the two
or three embryos that we're looking at
in the course of our analysis as you'll
see um we're actually a lot more
interested in the
SDC um but if we wanted to we could also
to study the
sste so if we uh step back and think
about these statistics that we've
described we ask obviously the question
of what can this variability tell us
about a group or population and cells
well if you think about SDC um low
levels of intercellular variability
reflect stable invariant expression okay
the gene is expressed homogeneously
pretty much amongst the cells that we're
looking at and as a result the level of
expression is highly predictable so that
if you were to sample any cell at random
from the embryo then uh we have a lot of
confidence in predicting What that
particular gene expression level would
be um if we contrast that and think
about genes that have high SDC or high
intracellular variability then this
reflects genes that have widely
distributed or variable expression and
in this case we think of a population of
cells and this Gene being being
expressed heterogeneously from cell to
cell and as a result then if we sample
it random from this population we have
less confidence in predicting what that
gene expression level should be um as we
saw before A diversity of different
expression States could actually lead to
cells that are undergoing transitions to
different cell States or maybe different
phenotypically for other
reasons so if we look at the global and
by glob what we mean across all genes
that we're looking at we can see that
intercellular variability actually
increases across development so you can
see the STC the distribution is
basically increased as we go from forell
to blast stages now this is obviously
probably not much of a surprise to
anyone we know that as embryos develop
the cells become much more heterogeneous
because they are undergoing
specialization to different lineages and
tissues and cell types Etc so it's it's
interesting to see that reflected in the
overall distributions um of the genes if
we look at sde sde as you recall
measures how consistent the
intercellular variability is between the
different embryos and we can see that
the stte is largely constant um or the
distributions are fairly overlapping as
we go from fossil to blasticus so in a
way this gives us confidence um it means
that the embryos are fairly stable if if
you like um and it it means it's a good
reason to study the intracellular
variability so if we look um a little
bit more carefully at the distributions
um as the embryos develop we notice too
that the global distribution of
intercellular variability spreads out
and here in these densities what I've
shown is the uh density of the SDC and
the sste where each point on the density
represents a a gene and the round dots
that you see at the bottom of the graph
represent the average expression
variability for that particular
developmental stage so the SD you can
see all the average expression
variabilities are actually sitting on
top of each other which is reflective of
the lack of difference or the lack of
shift that we see as the EMB is develop
in contrast the sdc's you can see that
even on average there is uh consistent
increase that we're seeing in the
distributions and what's interesting too
is as the embryos develop further we see
a widening in this distribution which
means that there are some parts of the
genome that have very stable expression
and there are other parts of the genome
that are have high variability um from
cell to cell in the embryo so oops um
sort out our
um oh there's my
okay so our interest therefore is to
look at these contrasting regions of the
genome and ask what genes are these and
whether specifically they target
different Pathways or processes that
require this difference and
variability so to do this uh we applied
a mixture modeling technique using
normal mixture models using the M
cluster our package and if you're not
familiar with mixture modeling basically
what this is is decomposing a specific
density into sub components that we can
then explain so for instance on the left
I've shown this cartoon where we've
identified three components and each of
these components then corresponds to a
subgroup of genes in our particular
setting and what we've done then is to
apply this to each of the densities we
obtain for each developmental stage and
you can see that for the STC for the
four cell stage we have four components
the eight cell stage we have three for
the morala we have three components and
for the blis we have
two
so uh what we want want to do then is to
identify whether these subgroups
correspond to an enrichment of certain
Pathways or processes and to do that
we're using um Medicore and Ingenuity
pathway analysis these are two software
tools that have um annotation terms and
functional annotation terms to identify
different kinds of uh Pathways involved
so what we do is we identify First the
subgroups using mixture modeling and we
look at the overlap um and assess the
significance of overlap with specific
Pathways from IPA and medical and we
assess the significance using fishous
exact test and adjust multiple testing
using false Discovery rate
Corrections so the results that we see
um are actually quite interesting uh for
the for stage we see uh that there is a
distinction between uh Pathways that
were enriched at the most stable group
versus the most variable subgroup and
for the most stable uh genes that had
the most stable gen uh variability sorry
the most stable expression the lowest
variability we see Pathways related to
um critical processes like cell cycle um
translation and transcription on the
other end when we look at the genes that
had the most variable expression we see
Pathways that are related more to me
metabolism so for instance and oxos um
we see
uh and sorry we also see um Pathways
that are related to apoptosis and cell
survival so this is really interesting
and and I just wanted to point out too
that all terms that we've reported here
are significant at a 005 P value you and
they're coming from metacore although we
see similar results in the IPA analysis
as well um this kind of cell cycle
versus apoptosis metabolism result is
something that we uh see persisting
through the different developmental
stages so for instance at the eth cell
stage for the most stably expressed
genes we also see Pathways related to
cell cycle and here we see some related
to DNA damage as well for the most
variable subgroup um we see one
apoptotic pathway that's significant for
this group of genes for the
morala um for the least variable
subgroup again we see these cell cycle
terms and for the for the most variable
group we actually do not see any
significance in the terms and that just
means that the genes that were in this
component that were identified were in
just so many different kinds of Pathways
and functions that but they weren't
significant enough to point to a
specific Trend or
enrichment and finally for the Blaster
stage we have two components and if you
look at the most stable and the most
variable it's almost like we have a flip
of the previous Pathways so for the most
stably expressed genes we see an
enrichment of again metabolic energy
generating related Pathways um like ox
Foss glycolysis and glucan Genesis um
for the most variable genes we actually
see the cell cycle and the DNA damage PA
plays come up and we're not sure really
what that is reflective of um perhaps
these genes and or these cells sorry are
now specializing into um other roles and
hence the reversal of of these energy
versus um sort of self survival kind of
Pathways um the other thing that we've
done in this analysis is to identify new
markers of each developmental stage
using measures of variability and if we
think about how we tend to find markers
based on expression this tends to uh be
based on average statistics so um we
look for an average and increase or a
decrease in expression between the
phenotypes that were contrasting but
when when we think about what's going on
in single cells um as we saw before
looking at averages may not be the whole
picture and we may in fact be missing
important shifts in expression so I've
just drawn a a a cartoon here that
reflects what's going on in the sense
that in an intermediate stage where
we're trying to identify markers for it
could be that we see a massive shift in
the Precision of expression of that
marro but on either side of that stage
we see a really noisy or heterogeneous
degree of expression so we asked um we
asked the data whether we could see
genes that fit this profile and in doing
so what we what we required was genes
that had a significant change in
variability um across all stages um we
use the lavine's test to test this we
also required that the STC for that
particular stage be less than the STC at
all of the stages and we also look for
an increase in F change for that
particular stage compared to all other
stages and as you can see from the box
plots we do find genes that fit this
criteria so if we look more carefully um
at the line profiles which is probably a
better way to view this we found 55
potential Mar genes for eight cell stage
um eight for Mara and 11 for blasticus
and just because we're running out of
time a bit I just wanted to highlight
really briefly what these profiles look
like for these potential markers now you
can see that for the moraly stage these
uh these genes are expressed quite
tightly and I just like to point out
each dot in these plots represents a
different cell um and one of the really
interesting genes here is
mesdc2 which is a mimal chaperon protein
for stem cell patenting and uh
development um and so this has an
obvious role in regulation of the embryo
um and what's interesting is some of
these other genes also have interesting
roles some of them obvious some of them
not but some genes are also uh lacking
information on what they do um in the
genome so it's interesting to pull out
more information and sort of infer how
they could be um potential markers or
potentially important uh to embryonic
development when we look at the blast
Tois um here we found 11 gen gen and
again some of these are functionally
very interesting one of them is epcam
epcam you've probably heard a lot uh if
you work with stem cells the embryonic
stem cells epcam is a potential marker
for vasis and it's involved in formation
of the
Trad um we also find some other
interesting genes and we're still in the
process of exploring their uh their
contribution to embryonic development
and their utility as a potential marker
of skill
AG so um we've done some analyses
focusing on how changes in variability
are important but another way of looking
at this is also to ask if genes that
have invariant expression or very stable
expression are they also important to
helping us understand how expression is
regulating embryonic development and
here I have to apologize for the typo in
my slides um X is about 6,000 so we
found about 6,000 genes that did not
have significant change in variability
and again for this we used the LaVine
test um and took those genes that were
not significant at the 05 level so what
happened was we took these 6,000 or so
genes and we clustered the variability
profiles across the different
developmental stages to identify what
kinds of patterns were present and as
you can see from the cluster profiles B
basically these fall into three groups
that uh reflect low medium and high
levels of stable expression and so what
we did was to then focus on the genes
that were in the most stable group so
these guys had the least variability
going from stage to stage and also had
the lowest uh level of variability um
compared to all the other groups so when
we look at the their correspond in
expression levels we noticed something
really interesting we saw that basically
these genes fell into three modes of
expression um which we've termed off on
and super on and so you can see at each
stage this Tri modal distribution is
apparent um and you can see how off
corresponds to zero uh very low average
uh expression on corresponds to like
middle level but certainly um moderate
to high levels expression and superon
corresponds to extremely high levels of
average expression in the embryo so to
Define these three groups of off on and
superon we use normal mixture models um
as we did before to identify which genes
were being classified into one of those
three groups and then what we did was we
looked at metacore and IPA to look for
enrichment of specific Pathways and
processes is at each developmental stage
so when we look at the on genes uh we
actually found that there were quite a
few genes that were um commonly
classified as on in all four stages and
so when we look at the pathways and
processes s were enriched in this group
we notice that there are some really
critical Pathways that are involved in
signaling and survival so for instance
E2 signaling um mtor signaling ubiquit
cell cycle and nucleotide exision repair
um are all represented amongst these gen
when we look at the ones at each stage
um we actually see there's quite a lot
of overlap in the terms that were
significant um and we can also actually
see that there was some uh terms that
were specific and these are indicated by
the stars that you
see um when we look at the off genes at
each stage um we also notice overlap and
the trend that's emerging here is that
these are terms that deal largely with
differentiation and development of
specialized cell types so it makes a lot
of sense as to why embryos would uh
prefer to turn these off in the cells
and consistently amongst all cells um
particularly as the embryos are a very
early stage of
development and then the superon geneses
uh that we see
are uh there are fewer enriched terms
here but the terms that we do see are
quite interesting and we see for the
first three stages um this consistent
term of differentiation of emonic stem
cells and this makes a lot of sense I
guess given the type of cells that we're
looking at for the blasticus we also saw
a term related to nadh repair and so
this uh suggests perhaps that there is
an energy demand which we know is
increasing blist and so perhaps by
turning these genes on consistently at
high levels in all cells this might be
supplying uh an increased energy demand
that's coming from the Blas is at this
stage of
development so I'm going to end my talk
there by just summarizing some of the
bullet points of our analysis um using
variability and also average expression
we've been able to identify some
putative mark markers through each of
the developmental stages um and some of
those markers seem quite plausible in
terms of what we already know about how
they contribute to regulation of
embryonic development we've shown that
globally um variability increases as the
Embry is develop which is in line with
our understanding of um differentiation
and and cell type specialization we've
also highlighted how distinct Pathways
and processes are under different levels
of regulatory control as these embryos
uh transitioned through development and
we've been able to identify too the the
pathways and genes that are more sta
expressed and how these make sense
hopefully to understanding how embryos
develop so I'd like to end there and um
acknowledge the people who are involved
in this work um you hasawa a student in
my lab and she's done the majority of
the analyses that I've described um
we've also uh been working with other
people in my group who have contributed
in various ways uh we collaborate with
Dr deian Taylor and her post. Jessica
Landis who are at reproductive Medical
associ Associates of New Jersey and
they've been really instrumental in
guiding the analyses that that we've
described so I'd like to end there and
thank you all for um your attention and
I'm going to just click on this Q&A box
here and answer the questions that have
been
submitted um so the first question comes
from Maria um and she says you mentioned
about enrich Pathways and functions is
there any reference related with this
point um if uh you're referring to the
method um Maria there is a lot of
literature I think associated with this
kind of enrichment um
analyses
um I'm just blanking at the moment uh
with the i I guess you could look at
different kinds of um software packages
for instance um gsca is one related uh
program it's available from the broad
institute there's also um a package
called David which is not what we used
um but this also um is a freeware tool
I'd encourage you to have a look at it
it's actually really really helpful and
there's references associated with that
um there are references Associated I
think with metacore and IPA as tool and
I think a quick Google puet search would
also um also uh lead you to to what
those are
specifically um if you mean references
related to the pathways the arch
Pathways that we discovered from this
analysis um these are there in the
analysis um that we got back um and we
we're in the process of looking at some
of those references um in particular the
pub net IDs as well that reference the
work that gave to those uh annotations
from the
literature um the next
question uh also from Maria um is was
there any in activation with ex
chromosones
um I
really don't uh I don't know if we have
the data to analyze that um I guess we
could look at transcription from jeans
on the XY chromosones
um but we we only have rna6 so I'm I'm
not sure about how to answer that
question
um the next question we have is
um is this a onetime point expression
profiling or over a period of time is
expression consistent for particular
differentiation or developmental stage
that's that's a a great question um the
expression profiling was done over over
a period of time um however it's
important to realize that we aren't
following or we aren't able to follow
the same embryo over um each
developmental stage so um we are looking
at snapshots um of distinct time points
but they are supposed to represent um a
longitudinal uh kind of change in
expression it just isn't on the same set
of cells um and is expression consistent
for particular differentiation or
development full stage um we do expect
um it is we do expect to see specific
sorry the question just disappeared um
we do expect to see uh consistent
patterns that represent each
developmental stage but obviously
there's a lot of variability in heading
going on so separating out that signal
to noise is is what we're also trying to
do um okay so the next question is is it
possible to have a sample for your
future publication about your results
yes that's an excellent question um
we're in the process of writing this uh
analysis up this has not been published
yet um but we definitely hope to have
that have a have that publication out
soon um and our last question uh deals
with again with x chromosone
um women suffered inactivation on one ex
chromosome the other chromosome ex
active
um is that something I'm I'm not sure
Maria I think it sounds like you may
know more about this than me um but if
that's something that we can see
transcriptionally then um we could look
for like a dosage effect I do think
though um we would still need to look at
more embryos uh than the number that we
have available to be able to study um
more concretely the contribution of the
ex
chromosone so I
think uh these are all the questions um
so I am going to end there and um please
feel free to follow up with questions
bya email I'd love to receive them and
thanks very much for your
time